the only way to succeed was through
failure Michael Jordan missed 50 of his
shots the best baseball players in the
world failed 70 of the time and they
were the best in athletics we were
taught that Baylor is just feedback it's
a part of the process and how you
succeed a child when learning to walk
Falls a thousand times and never thinks
to himself maybe this walking thing
isn't for me he just keeps getting up
and trying again until he figures out
how to walk yes certainly a healthy
relationship with failure and reframing
that one of the problems that you have
in the modern world is this asymmetry
between what we see of everybody else I
see of ourselves you get to see the
grand failures of people with the
bankruptcies and the house going up in
flame and what you don't see the way
that they made a promise to themselves
that they weren't going to hit snooze
this week and yet they did those very
mundane failures it's hard to find the
balance